[Applause]
shot clock is off Warriors down three
double team
Jordan pool lets it fly no long rebound
to Schroeder clock ticks and finally a
whistle comes and it's going to be a
time-out Lakers
Jordan Poole fired up
a 28-footer
[Applause]
but a great job by the Lakers in
transition coming to double Curry and
make him give the ball up pool got an
open look but look at that point in the
game when you're playing the Golden
State Brian it's ABC anyone but curry
good call
great play there by Schroeder he Tracked
Down The Rebound he was able to get the
timeout to secure the possession for the
Lakers
Warriors do not have a foul to give here